doch einfach so dass wir schon aus den
erfahrungen unserer nachbarländer aber
auch aus berchtesgaden wissen auch nach
einem knallharten locker und dauert es
relativ lange bis die zahlen runter
gehen und es ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass wir am zehnten
januar aufwachen und wir sind dann schon
bei 50 oder weniger angekommen dann ist
immer noch winter und nach vorne gedacht
bis zum frühjahr brauchen wir eine neue
strategie und das ist es was wir in
tübingen zu ergänzen versucht haben
ich will aber noch einmal erläutern was
meiner meinung nach getan werden könnte
bis zum 10
januar damit wir nicht jetzt in den
langen lockdown hineinrutschen
da ist zum einen das test regime wir
haben eben einen thüringen seit august
versucht sehr engmaschig zu testen das
personal die besucher und die bewohner
von pflegeheimen bis anfang dieser woche
haben das geschafft ist wer was nicht
rein zu lassen
wir konnten es aber nur freiwillig tun
jetzt wird endlich eine pflicht zu
diesen tests eingeführt nach meiner
meinung der auch niemand mehr einen
pflegeheim rein der sich mit einem
eingang getestet wurde und dann müsste
es uns gelingen dass wir uns da draußen
zu halten und es wird ein großteil der
todesfälle unter belastung unserer
intensivstationen vermeiden